Edgar ever never might be charming and
oh so accommodating but he's got
ulterior motives written all over his
face it's clear that he's the biggest
threat Riverdale has yet to go up
against but from the looks of it only
Betty Cooper is hot on his trail well
Veronica Jughead and Archie join Betty's
plight against the growing cult or do
they already have enough on their plates
watch until the end to find out why the
little town of Riverdale might get wiped
off the map completely I believe the
farm can help you see that the one and
only
Edgar ever never things haven't been
looking too good for a Riverdale ever
since Edgar ever never moved to town the
mysterious new-age health guru hasn't
been wasting any time however he still
managed to keep a low profile
the infamous cult leader has been
gaining popularity and lost souls are
currently flocking to his cause we've
known about Edgar for quite some time
now but we only just got to see him in
chapter 51 big fun this Heather's
musical inspired episode made way for
Edgar's big debut fans were thrilled to
see actor Chad Michael Murray slow
clapping his way into the limelight
but that doesn't make them any less
suspicious in Chapter 52 the raid we
finally get to see Edgar flash across
the screen for more than a second it's
obvious that he's a true born cult
leader after all he's got away with
words and knows how to charm a crowd
from the looks of it Edgar knows how to
utilize a lost soul which is probably
why his daughter Evelyn often does his
evil bidding if there's one thing we
couldn't help but notice it's that Edgar
or Eddy as Cheryl likes to call him
seems way too young to be the father of
a 17-year old teenager this brings us to
our first theory Evelyn isn't Edgar's
real daughter Evelyn ever never is
Little Miss Perfect and she's also
daddy's little girl she's often seen
boasting about her incredible father and
his lavish community the farm
she's been recruiting damaged teenagers
to her father's side since we first met
her in Chapter 37 Fortune and men's eyes
so what the heck is up with this MIDI
gritty character we don't know about you
but we highly doubt that Evelyn is
Edgar's trueborn daughter she's much too
young
and seems a little too obsessed with
that girl in fact some might even think
that she's in love with him
so here's our theory Edgar adopted
Evelyn from the sisters of quiet mercy
when she was just a kid he trained her
to become his master recruiter like mini
cult leaders often do we're also not so
sure that Evelyn is as young as she
looks
in fact she's so mature it's a little
freaky could Evelyn be posing as a
student to get close to the young and
vulnerable teens in Riverdale well at
this point we wouldn't be surprised
here's another theory that might just
knock your socks off Edgar is totally
obsessed with redheads remember when
Betty told Cheryl that Evelyn was trying
to recruit her well we think Edgar is
the one who put her up to it although
this might seem a little random hear us
out first of all Edgar never conducts
interviews with newcomers but he showed
up to greet Cheryl like it was no big
deal
we're pretty sure that he also recruited
Ethel mugs you know the Griffins and
gargoyles fanatic who also happens to be
a redhead
on top of that Cheryl's twin was a
redhead and seems to be shackled up at
the farm as well and most of all
everyone is after the red paladin and
hello Archie is the number one redhead
in town heck even miss Grundy seems to
have an affinity for red-headed students
in ancient civilization redheads were
believed to have magical powers could
this be why Edgar is giving redheads
special handouts because if so he's
about to get caught red-handed okay
all right enough about redheads it's
time to focus on everyone's favorite
blonde bombshell who will Betty see out
of everyone in Riverdale Betty Cooper
has the most reasons to be a lost little
soul not only is her father a psychopath
serial killer but her mother is a cult
member with a hidden agenda on top of
that her sister is completely unhinged
and Betty is responsible for Hix demise
she's got a boatload of secrets that she
doesn't want the public to know about
and Edgar ever never has them all on
tape luckily for Betty she has a good
head on her shoulders and isn't
susceptible to the onslaught of powerful
men she's hell-bent on cracking
Riverdale's biggest mystery but there's
one thing standing in her way
Evelyn ever never
looks of it Betty will have to pull off
the performance of a lifetime to get
accepted into the farm here she'll be
able to see why her friends and family
members have joined Edgar's forces so
who do you guys think Betty will see in
Edgar's death-defying chamber we'd put
our money on chicks after all but he
definitely feels guilty for delivering
him to her father so seeing him alive
and well might help her forgive herself
but would chicks livelihood be enough to
convert her for real
we wouldn't state our reputation on it
the twin conspiracy from the very
beginning Riverdale has made it
painfully obvious that twins play a huge
role in the series mini mysteries so
we're just waiting for the other shoe to
drop this shoe in particular is a red
stiletto belonging to Cheryl blossom who
might just be getting the wake-up call
of a lifetime despite being twins Cheryl
and Jason looked nothing alike that is
except for their stellar red hair of
course so here's our Theory Cheryl isn't
actually Jason's twin nope we think that
just like her mother Cheryl was adopted
by the blossoms when she was just a baby
and Jason's real twin was separated from
him at birth and stored for another
purpose have you guys ever wondered why
Jason was a year older than Cheryl and
dating Penny's older sister well that
makes two of us is it possible that the
blossoms adopted Cheryl and groomed her
to become Jason's wife if so history was
seriously about to repeat itself but we
what happened to jason's real twin could
he be the one we saw Clifford blossom
chute in season one if so this could
explain why Cheryl saw Jason and Edgar
special chamber Edgar took me to a room
close the door and there was Jason
despite him being uh long gone and all
we've got another twin theory coming up
so stick around meanwhile let's focus on
Betty and Evelyn's very obvious feud
that's undoubtedly going to escalate as
the season 3 finale comes to a close
Evelyn is coming after Betty when we
first meet Evelyn ever never we see her
try to befriend Betty in the blue and
gold office she comes off as strange and
manipulative which immediately sounds
Betty's alarms from then on Betty and
Evelyn have clearly
had it in for each other but in the most
low-key way possible it's amazing that
Betty has managed to keep her rage to
herself
especially since Evelyn's interference
has caused Betty her childhood home
college fund and family well it looks
like dark Betty is coming back to town
because she's definitely at her breaking
point they've released a short promo of
episode 18 and it's here that we see
Betty Cooper looser cool she slams
Evelyn into the wall and tells her she's
going to kill her although Evelyn may
come off as sweet and innocent she's got
a murderous look in her eye and we
wouldn't put it past her to do anything
it takes to ensure that the farm
succeeds after Betty's threat Evelyn
might take it upon herself to get rid of
the ever so curious Betty Cooper
so guys beware the real Evelyn might
soon show her face the Living Dead if
there's one thing that's got Riverdale
fans shook it's the fact that Alice
Cooper and Cheryl blossom just admitted
to seeing dead people with their own two
eyes
now that's seriously messed up but
seeing as it's not the first time
Riverdale folk have seen things that
weren't really there we wouldn't be
surprised if their reveries turned out
to be hallucinations are we the only
ones who noticed that Kevin saw midge
after accepting one of Evelyn's homemade
brownies we don't think so much like the
sisters of quiet mercy used to
jingle-jangle to convince their patients
that the gargoyle King was real Edgar
could be using the same substance to
fool his cult members he might be
serving them some herbal tea with his
sight of jingle asking them about their
deceased loved ones and then making them
believe they're still alive but only at
the farm what do you guys think are
these people alive or are they the
result of an intoxicated heavy conscious
alive and well we promised you another
twin theory and here's it's better half
Jason faked his death to be with Polly
on the farm so it's very possible that
Cheryl did indeed come face-to-face with
the living and breathing Jason blossom
although we like to believe that witches
and wizards are real we don't think
Edgar has any magical powers whatsoever
so something fishy is definitely going
on here's what we really think is
happening the blossoms gave one of their
twin boys up to the sisters of quiet
mercy in exchange for Cheryl this way
the blossom twin curse would
never come true then Edgar adopted
Jason's real twin chick Evelyn and
Charles Cooper and raised them as his
own children
he made Chuck pretend to be Charles
leading to the Cooper's committing a
string of crimes this served as
blackmail and now Edgar's got Betty's
freedom wrapped around his finger
since the blossoms and the Cooper's are
the oldest families in Riverdale
controlling them would mean controlling
the entire town so basically Polly and
Sheryl believed Jason to be alive but in
reality they're dealing with Jason's
long-lost twin and Alice is truly seeing
Charles
however she believes it to be a miracle
because Charles convinced her that he
had passed away soon Edgar will have
recruited the main Riverdale families
and will be able to take over the town
but what on earth is he planning to do
with it Edgar is the gargoyle king
Riverdale fans have pointed accusatory
fingers at warden Norton Hiram Lodge
Penelope blossom and even Hal Cooper but
they have all managed to maintain their
innocence or now since Edgar and Evelyn
ever never moved to Riverdale around the
same time Griffin's and gargoyles became
a hot commodity
we suspect that these two groups are
linked after all the sisters of quiet
Mercy have been scaring their patients
into submission by using the gargoyle
Kings rule for decades and since Edgar
is now using the sisters of quiet Mercy
as his headquarters we were led to
believe that he's doing this for a
reason
although Evelyn is never showcased
playing the deadly quest game she
doesn't seem to be threatened by it
which is peculiar could Edgar be the
gargoyle King or is he playing a
different game entirely
ascension night Edgar ever never might
come off as a kind generous and soothing
guru but he's a villain if we've ever
seen one cult leaders are often charming
and gifted with silver tongues and the
whisper into vulnerable people's ears
until they get what they want power and
money by now it's obvious that Ascension
Night is going to be a pretty big deal
and since Griffins and gargoyles players
keep poisoning themselves with cyanide
we're led to believe that the show is
mimicking real-life events on November
18 1978 a horrendous event that is now
referred to as Jonestown took place this
deadly affair is living proof of how
dangerous Colts can
be the cult in question was named
people's temple agricultural project
which has a lot in common with the farm
so we believe that Edgar ever never is
recruiting people giving them what they
want
accumulating their life savings and
preparing them for ascension aka death
by fresh aid Jonestown claimed its
victims by poisoning a large barrel of
flavor aid which sounds a lot like what
is happening in Riverdale if Edgar is
truly the ruthless cult leader we
believe him to be
he'll probably trick his followers into
drinking the kool-aid before taking off
with their life savings so when will
ascension night happened probably when
the sociopathic Edgar ever never gets
bored with reigning supreme what do you
want to know does this theory seem too
far-fetched or are we on to something
let us know in the comments give this
video a big thumbs up if you think
Archie Veronica Betty and Jughead will
join forces to take Edgar down before
you go make sure to subscribe to the
themes to catch the latest Riverdale
news thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]